In this lesson, we'll learn how to split the data.
First, we have the training data, this is the data that we use to train a model.
Secondly, we have validation data, this data is used to select a model.
Third, we have the test data,
this is the data we use to report the performance of a model.
Now, training is error is used to tune the performance of
the model on the training set.
A validation error is used to select the model that works best among
many models.
We then use the test error to calculate the performance of
the model that we have already selected.
In the next few videos, we will introduce each of these errors and
how we use them to make the decision to eventually use a specific model to solve
our problem, and to identify cars in the connected cars data set.
There are no general rules how best one should split the data for
each of the three purposes.
Depending on the size or the volume of the data set, one would decide to split
in proportion of 50 for training, 25 to validate and 25 to test.
Often, one might need more for training or validation.
There are also constraints from the model itself and
the complexity at which we build the model.
We will talk about model complexity shortly.
It is important to note that the test data needs to be
set aside until a particular validated model has been selected.
This gives us an unbiased estimate of the performance of the model.
More specifically, when we are building the model,
we do not examine the test data at all.
This is to avoid biasing our results on the test set.
This is an essential part of the validation process.